in a historic move Northern California
voters have recalled a judge from office
over a controversial sentencing decision
The Associated Press projects that
nearly 60% of voters in Santa Clara
County chose to remove Judge Aaron
Persky he's the first California judge
to be recalled in 86 years Persky was
targeted for giving a short jail
sentence to brock Turner a former
Stanford University swimmer convicted of
sexual assault with the intent to commit
rape John Blackstone is in Palo Alto
California with reaction to the vote
John good morning good morning well this
case drew outrage from around the world
but the recall raised questions of
judicial independence now the final vote
tally won't be in for days probably but
as soon as the counting started last
night the trend was obvious judge Persky
was likely to lose his job here at the
Santa Clara County Superior Court women
are standing up and saying enough is
enough it was a night of victories for
Stanford Law Professor Michelle Dawber
who led a campaign for nearly two years
to remove Judge Aaron Persky from the
bench sexual violence and violence
against women is a voting issue Dawber
harnessed widespread anger over Persky
sentencing of brock Turner Turner was
freed from County Jail after serving
just three months of his six month
sentence for sexually assaulting a woman
following a fraternity party at Stanford
her searing statement about the impact
of sexual assault was read to Turner in
court and widely shared I accept
responsibility for every decision that
I've made as a judge in his only
television interview before the recall
vote Persky defended the sentence you
did have some idea before you passed the
sentence that it would be a
controversial sentence yes and by my
ethical constraints by the rule of law I
had to completely tune that out persky's
supporters insisted judges should not be
held hostage to public opinion this
recall is a very serious threat to do
retired Superior Court judge ladoris
Cordell campaign to keep Persky on the
bench
they're targeting a judge with no
history or track record of bias who did
nothing wrong and made a lawful decision
and they have succeeded in taking his
job away but Dawber stands by her
campaign
Tuesday night she ended it with the
words Turner's victim read in court two
girls everywhere we are with you on
nights when you feel alone we are with
you
Cordell said she spoke with Persky last
night and while he's disappointed with
the outcome he's doing ok she said he's
a licensed lawyer and he can practice
law but she worries that this vote sends
a message to judges everywhere that if
you do your job and people don't like it
you could be fired John John Blackstone
thanks